well during the pandemic many people
picked up new hobbies
like gardening and now during our spring
you know you may be looking for ways to
spruce up that garden or even your
household plants
bianca holdman is live to share how
something called composting could give
you that green
thumb advantage you know a lot of us
think we're going to start composting
bianca but we
never quite really do it so
tell us more about it right it's always
on our to-do list oh let me get to it
i'm gonna get to it well start today
okay
you may be cleaning up from breakfast
but go ahead and grab that apple car
and also the skin from your avocado
after you make your avocado toast before
you throw it in the trash
take it put it to the side put it in a
nice little baggie and this compost as
it breaks down it can create
luscious life to your plants to your
herbs that you may be growing
either indoors or even your outdoor
garden so some more about composting we
learned a lot this week in talking with
the folks over at
the republic services company now
transforming your yard and food scraps
into compost not only can give you
life to your plants but it can also help
save the environment
matter of fact back in 2020 republic
services processed more than 2 billion
pounds of organic
waste that of course went back into the
ground
it's a pretty good feeling when you can
start using your compost and you see the
benefits from it uh
just yesterday i was out in the garden
and i was harvesting some nice red ripe
stripes and strawberries
um this last year we've been able to
start using our compost
quite frequently and we're definitely
seeing the difference
in last year's garden yield versus this
year's and that's directly related to
compost so it's exciting
it's exciting to see that your hard work
is actually doing something good
for sure so if you want a sense of
accomplishment here are some
tips to help you get started so the
right tools are very very necessary a
compost bin inside to collect your
scraps
and then a bin outside it to let the
organic material break down
and this space should be definitely
shaded and dry that's outdoors and after
you're set up you'll have to monitor it
to ensure it's balanced
and if it starts to attract bugs you may
need to add more brown materials you
want to make sure that there's enough
kind of dry materials
and some of our wet materials keep it
balanced so if it starts to get a little
too wet and their bugs over there add
some more brown if it's a little bit too
dry
then add some more wet products and so
of course again all great tips to help
you
spruce up your garden or your indoor
plants back to you guys in the studio